There are a small number of gutsy Hollywood
stars who insist on doing their own stunt
work.
But because most A-listers are happy to hand
the really dangerous stuff over to the professionals,
stunt doubles are always in demand in Tinseltown.
Unfortunately, not every stunt has a happy
ending.
Brushes with death are an occupational hazard
for Hollywood stunt doubles — and these
were some of the most hazardous.
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows - Part
Warner Bros. tried to use practical effects
whenever possible in their Harry Potter series,
especially when it came to broomsticks.
That didn't mean the studio was happy to put
its star witches and wizards on those broomsticks,
however.
Stuntman David Holmes doubled for Daniel Radcliffe
in many scenes, all the way back to the first
film.
During Deathly Hallows Part 1, Holmes was
filming a flying stunt when he was yanked
from his broom and slammed into a wall before
falling to the ground.
The accident broke his neck and left him paralyzed
at the age of 25.
Holmes told The Mirror,
"I remember slipping in and out of consciousness
because of the pain levels."
"I knew I had really done some damage."
Radcliffe himself thinks of Holmes as a friend
rather than a colleague, and hosted a charity
auction to help Holmes pay for his medical
bills.
Back to the Future Part II
The hoverboard scene is one of the most memorable
moments from Back to the Future Part II, though
for stunt performer Cheryl Wheeler, it brings
back painful memories, since she was almost
killed shooting the sequence.
"arrrrrgh!"
One stuntwoman had already quit over the scene,
and Wheeler became concerned after a handful
of last-minute changes were made to the rig.
After being accused of getting cold feet,
the stunt coordinator threatened to put a
male stunt performer in her clothes for the
scene.
Being new to the business and wanting to make
an impression, she reluctantly agreed.
Instead of crashing through the sugar glass
window, Wheeler collided with a stone pillar
and was dropped 30 feet onto the concrete
below, missing the fall mats entirely.
Fellow stunt performer Gary Morgan recalled
in the book We Don't Need Roads,
"I got up and Cheryl was laying on the concrete
and the pool of blood by her head was getting
bigger.
I thought she was dead."
Fortunately, Cheryl was quickly back in action,
and is still performing stunts as recently
as 2015.
The Expendables 2
Countless henchmen are maimed and killed during
the many explosions that take place throughout
Sylvester Stallone's Expendables films, though
one of them actually claimed a life for real.
Stuntman Kun Lieu was fatally injured during
the filming of a scene in Bulgaria involving
an inflatable raft for The Expendables 2.
While Lieu's life could not be saved, his
partner during the stunt, Nuo Sun, somehow
escaped with his.
According to court papers, Sun sustained damage
to his "nervous system, neck, head, body [and]
arms," which left him in "great mental, physical
and nervous pain and suffering."
The stunt performer sued Millennium Films
for $25,000 as well as the cost of his lengthy
hospital treatment and recovery.
Today, Sun continues to work in the stunt
department of films like Ant-Man and Logan.
Resident Evil: The Final Chapter
Star Milla Jovovich said that it was a "miracle"
her double survived an incident that took
place on the set of 2016's Resident Evil:
The Final Chapter, which left a British stuntwoman
in a coma.
According to a Facebook post by Jovovich,
"My incredibly talented stunt double, Olivia
Jackson, collided with a camera crane while
performing a motorcycle stunt and it put her
in the hospital with severe, multiple injuries."
After she regained consciousness, Jackson
also took to Facebook to reveal the horrifying
extent of the damage, which included a degloved
face, brain swelling, an amputated thumb,
and a missing piece of bone.
She called the incident, quote, "not her funnest
day on set".
In the end, one of Jackson's arms had to be
amputated.
The resilient Brit posted a picture of her
"twisted upper body" to her Instagram feed
in January 2017, claiming that her off-centered
neck is the most painful part, saying,
"I don't mean to moan, but sometimes I just
want to crawl out of my own skin and all the
pains in it."
For what it's worth, she seems to be keeping
in good spirits about her injuries.
The Hangover Part II
Australian stuntman Scott McLean was doubling
for funnyman Ed Helms in The Hangover Part
2 when the stunt drivers involved in the film's
car chase reportedly got their marks wrong,
and McLean's head was hit by a truck.
He suffered a critical head injury, forcing
hospital staff to put him in a medically induced
coma.
McLean was feared dead by his colleagues after
the impact, and while he ultimately escaped
with his life, his lawyers claim he suffered
permanent brain injuries.
His wife commented,
"There was so much damage.
He was a mess.
He used to look after me, now it's my turn
to look after him for a change."
McLean's life will never be the same despite
extensive therapy, but today, he speaks openly
and positively about his recovery.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!